[Music]
- action
[Music]
I've stunt doubles with Daniel Craig
Jake Gyllenhaal Ryan Reynolds Christian
Bale Chris Hemsworth Chris Evans Chris
Pine all the Chris's
[Music]
[Music]
and it was on like a ram system with the
rigging the rigging boy put together we
tested it you know Safety's a massive
thing for any stunt performer and
containment we've spent a lot of time in
rehearsal area and break things down
[Music]
that was actually my first ever fire
bone
[Music]
special effects teams are incredible
when I got jerked through the glass
because the glass piece was so big it
had to be you know it's rogar a
split-second before I hit the glass they
would depth you know get the glass with
you know they've got a system you know
where they've got debt inside the glass
and it would crack all the glass and
then I would make the rest of the the
rest of the break by going through it
you get a couple of little Nick's on the
back your head and you know on your neck
or and hands and whatever ups you know
it's it's about making movies and being
able to continue to make them and not do
anything stupid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't be in the movies doing the
stunts and then people say oh that was
definitely not the actor you know we
want to try and try and portray that
actress all that character as much as we
possibly can watch exactly how the actor
walks you know how they move that part
of our job to take on
actual movies I believe can't be made
unless you've got a you know really
disgusting
[Music]